monsters
out of the season this was by far my
favorite routine he did an incredible
job on it he's literally a genius and he
did such a great job of you know really
channeling my strengths and putting that
into the dance and I I mean you can't
help but feel powerful during that dance
it was incredible and I'm so happy that
we were able to go out on that note at
the beginning of the season I was very
scared and just terrified of putting
myself out there on a live television
show and doing something that I'm not
used to doing and I just went for it so
to make it this far and being so
unfamiliar with the space that I was in
I'm very proud of myself and I couldn't
have done it without this guy so I'm
feeling really good one thing I love
about her you know no matter what she
does she always has a smile on her face
she always has a laugh in her inner
voice you know what I mean and I love
that about her I think it's such an
amazing quality and it certainly
brightens everybody's day you know
whatever you know person she's around
she just brightens their day up and it's
an amazing quality to have one thing I
learned from winning on the show is that
it really isn't about winning it's about
being proud of what you've done because
there's been Seasons when I've won I was
I'm not gonna lie I was kind of like I
could have done better you know I mean
truthfully and Seasons I didn't win and
I was like more proud about it so this
season I'm very very proud of like what
we accomplished and what we did there's
some really fun memorable moments so